David is it possible that running Trump
in 2024 could actually be a disaster for
the Republican party yeah I mean listen
if they lose it's bad a lot of this
stuff is figured out in retrospect
um if if Trump runs in 24 and loses then
yeah it's bad if Trump runs in 24 and
wins then it's good by definition
because they won but I think that the
the better lens through which we should
view it is
even Republicans who don't like Trump
agree that having Trump for four years
was better than having Hillary and when
you understand that you get a sense of
the reality that even if I mean listen
Trump 2016 was a disaster for the
Republican Party Trump won
they lost the house in 2018 they lost
the senate in 2020 they lost the White
House in 2020 2022 to be determined how
they do
uh so it was a disaster to run Trump and
yet the Republican party is still mostly
United they're overwhelmingly behind
Donald Trump two-thirds of them say they
would follow Donald Trump to a third
party if that's what it came down to in
order to keep supporting Donald Trump so
there's a reason that the Republican
Party continues to embrace him big
picture despite the fact that he lost
everything for them and it's become
really really clear over the last uh
okay five years ten years even really
starting with the bush era although
during the Obama phase it really kicked
up Republicans have given up on policy
and you know oh we're about fiscal
conservatism no they criticize the
budget as a political cudgel they use it
as a cudgel but then when their guy
blows up the budget they don't say a
word about it uh they say support the
troops except when they don't and they
say support the police except when they
don't all of this stuff is bogus they've
given up on policy given that now the
Republican party has decided that
they're basically going to be a you know
Meme and own the left type party focused
on talking about communism and socialism
and this type of thing in a sense
Trump's a good candidate for that
because Trump number one brought in
people who don't care about policy and
never did and weren't engaged in
politics and for the first time they
paid attention because they like the
idea of how Trump talked and the fact
that it wasn't about policy it was just
about meming essentially trolling in
some sense
um and even establishment Republicans
who may not like that
realize well if it's Trump or Hillary 99
of us still prefer Donald Trump so when
we say could 2024 be a disaster for the
Republican party it could be bad for
them and that they might lose and they
might lose really really bad like they
did in 2018 and 2020. but as far as
fracturing and destroying the Republican
party if anything has been proven uh
over the last
four months I guess or you know six
since the election or wait how many has
it been no it's been uh eight months
since the election that's crazy if
anything has been proven it's that even
when they lose Republicans still seem
very United that even a mediocre
candidate as they may see Trump some of
them is better than Hillary it's better
than Joe Biden and so from that
standpoint I don't think it will be
terrible for Republicans to run Trump in
2024. you know what if he loses they'll
be energized again the way many of them
are energized right now if you disagree
with me
send me your thoughts also make sure
that you are signed up at joinpakman.com
so that you get access to the bonus show
on which today we will be discussing
many exciting and important stories we
will see you then